hey guys it's justine and today's video
is going to be so exciting
if you can't tell we have every color of
the new m1 imac
right here and guess what we're gonna
unbox them so let's get started
this is an a fort of imax it's honestly
the coolest thing ever
it's like a golden egg wow
oh that's gold that's gold oh
yellow accessories it's exciting
every single time
[Music]
[Applause]
this is just a pure golden egg this
reminds me of the easter egg hunts that
we used to have with my family
because we'd always hide a golden egg
jenna golden egg found it
now that is yellow that is some
yellow if i've ever seen it wow
if you like the color yellow you're
going to be really into this
hello
this is a nice subtle yellow this
is aggressive that's kind of the theme
here we've got subtlety and then we have
this aggressive
darker color look at you
[Music]
it's so beautiful it's like i'm holding
nothing i think the ipad 12.9 inch
is heavier than this
[Music]
hello
this is so light look how pretty this is
it's the ethernet port look how
[Music]
pretty
it's a braided cable lightning to usbc
to match this braided cable for the
extension
[Music]
time to unbox the purple one i think i
actually might need my knife for this
i just got a peek of this color it's so
pretty
these colors are so awesome
you're seeing these things in the photos
but in person
it's really hard to even explain how
beautiful they look
hello goodbye
i have a feeling i'm going to be saying
that i like each color more than the
last
every single time i unbox i love that
they decided to make everything match
and look consistent
it really works
[Music]
and now we've moved on to the orange
imac
whoa this is like more of like a peach
kind of color
oh this has sara dietschy's name all
over it i
actually really like this color now
wow
[Music]
it's exciting every single time this is
so orange
it's a nice peach stickers
i mean they color match this perfectly
on to the next color and now we've got
the silver imac
it looks very nice so far
oh yeah look at this look at you
i feel like this is probably gonna be
one of the top sellers
just because it's a very simple basic
color what i'm gonna just
advise you guys take a look at these
other colors
they're beautiful or be basic do
whatever you want you do you jenna is
off
on the side of the camera setting up all
the computers
behind the scenes jenna so if you do
decide to get the silver
imac you're only going to get one
sticker
[Music]
the silver is nice it's actually all one
consistent color so in the other colors
the back was darker but this is all
one very nice solid color
i've said every single one looks great
and here's the silver this one really
does look
really nice i love it because it kind of
has like that minimalistic look the back
is the same color as the stand
so everything is very minimal and it
looks really sleek
[Music]
so this is the blue imac
it's so pretty what a great blue
it's oh it's like the ocean it's a
beautiful baby blue ocean
i know i've already unboxed six of these
but i just can't get over
the beautiful matching accessories
this blue is also really pretty surprise
goodbye check out these colors
these two blues look so pretty together
i love this dark blue
[Music]
we have one more to unbox time for the
green imac
oh man every single time i am shocked
by the color what it actually looks like
with my real
eyes
wow this color is great absolutely love
it
it's like everything is beautifully
color-coded even
the instructions so this looks like
one of the lower end models because it
only has two thunderbolt and usb4 ports
so glad that we have a variety this is
really nice i love
this color teal look at
this man so
[Music]
pretty
okay is that a wrap on green i think so
all right green
you're wrapped round applause
[Music]
so now let's set up all of these imacs
so now it's time to boot all of these up
it's kind of like a little race i've got
them all plugged in my cable management
is
very subpar but that is not important
today
let's go
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did make sure to give it a thumbs up be
sure to subscribe and hit the bell so
you notified when i post a new video
i would love to know from you guys
though which color is your favorite
i think that the pink is my favorite
next purple
blue teal the silver then the orange
and then the yellow obviously these
computers are beautiful but they're also
equally as powerful
so i will be doing a full review so make
sure you guys check out that i'll put a
link in the description
and with that i will see you guys in my
next video